♪ Dans ma cour ♪
♪ Il y avait
tout ce qu'il faut ♪
- Guylaine Tremblay, pour la
première fois de votre carrière,
vous y allez avec un spectacle
autobiographique. Je pense
que la base de votre nouveau
spectacle autobiographique,
c'est de dire : "Yvon Deschamps
m'a fait prendre conscience
de bien des choses."
- Ah! oui! Professeur...
- Comment? Ah! oui?
GUYLAINE TREMBLAY, comédienne
- Professeur dans la vie.
Oui, un professeur...
Souvent, quand on est enfant...
Il faut que je sois très, très
honnête avec vous, par exemple.
J'avais un gros kick dessus
quand j'avais 8 ou 9 ans.
- Oh!
- Souvent, tout commence par
un kick, hein! Il faut bien se
le dire. À 9 ans, en tout cas,
moi, je le trouvais beau.
♪ J'sais pas comment ♪
♪ J'sais pas pourquoi ♪
♪ Faut touj
que je me retrouve là ♪
uvuvuvuvais que ce petit oeil-là
pétillant d'intelligence,
moqueur, mais en même temps,
il y avait une douceur
déjà que moi je sentais
nsnsnsns ce regard-là.
Moi, je le trouvais beau.
Moi, tu m'aurais donné le choix
entre un joueur de football
puis Yvon Deschamps, j'aurais
pris Yvon Deschamps, n'importe
quand! J'étais attirée par...
par ce qu'il dégageait.
Donc, c'était ça, au début,
c'était : Ah! Il est beau,
Yvon Deschamps! Comme toutess s.
T'sais, quand on a un petit kick
sur quelqu'un! Puis après,
11 ans, 12 ans, là, je me mets
à écouter ses textes et àles co.
J'ai toujours le kick dessus.
J'aurai toujours le kick dessus;
Judi, elititititit!
- Donc, c'est dit, ça?
- C'est réglé. Il a 86 ans, j'ai
le kick dessus, c'est pas grave!
- Dans la vie, il y a deux
ch c c c c comptent : une job
steady puis un bon boss!
Toutes les maudites affaires
d'union puis de bébelles
de même, qu'ossa donne, ça?
- Mais quand même, on sent
que des monologues comme
"Les Unions, qu'ossa donne?"
d'Yvon Deschamps vous ont
vraiment marquée, entre autres,
sur votre vision de la justice,
sur le monde qui vous entoure.
De quelle façon?
- Bien moi, je viens d'un milieu
ouvrier. Donc, déjà, en partant,
je m'identifiais beaucoup
à Yvon Deschamps, qui vie
d'un milieu populaire et ouvrier
comme moi. Donc, d'entendre
"Les Unions, qu'ossa donne?",
c'est sûr que je regardais mon
père, mes oncles, s.s.s.s.s.s.
Puis, je me disais très,
très naïvement... parce que
je devais avoir 10 ou 11 ans,
quand c'est sorti, "Les Unions,
qu'ossa donne?
J'espère que mon père,
il se fait pas faire ça...
par son patron! Puis, si oui,
il faut se battre, il faut
pas... t'sais, il faut pas que
ça arrive. Alors, très vite,
j'ai eu... Ça a réveillé ma
capacité à m'indigner, si vous
voulez, contre les injustices.
Et puis, je suis devenue comme
une adolescente très militante,
moi, ouais. J'étais fatigante.
- Vous avez parlé de votre
adolescence, mais vous avez fait
des études au Conservatoire
d'art dramatique de Québec.
- Ouais.
- Puis, en 1983, on a
des ims s s s s s s voit
au Sommet de la jeunesse
où vous faites la comique?
- Oui! Bien oui! Bien oui!
Je me suis tellement cachée...
- En arrière de ça, moi,
faire la comique!
- Ah! oui?
- Bien ouiÇa me fait penser : Js
oublié de te dire, là, c'est
à propos des journalistes...
- Vous vous cachiez à travers
le comique?- Ah! bien oui!
Parce que c'était plus...
c'était plus facile pour moi.
Moi... Ça paraît pas, mais
je suis quelqu'un de très
pudique. Mais quand tu fais
ta comique, que tu te mets une
perruque puis des lunettes puis
que tu composes un langage,
tout ça, tu disparais, toi.
Toi, t'es plus là.
Alors, un moment donné,
les professeurs, ils ont dit :
"Ça va faire, là, la perruque,
les lunettes, Guylaine!
Là, on veut te voir, toi."
- OK. Mais quand même, ça vous a
suivi parce qu'il y a Caro, dans
"La petite vie". Vous avez joué
dans un "Ding et Dong,
le film" aussi...
- Ouais.
- Le comique est resté toujours.
- Bien, j'adore ça. J'adore ça.
C'est sûr que moi...
T'sais, j'adore changer,
de toute façon. Je pourrais pas
faire juste de drame ou juste
de la comédie. Ce métier-là me
donne une libert
là-dedans. Mais le rire, c'est
quand même assez formidable.
Comment ça se fait que Rod
a le droit de prendre la char
puis moé j'ai jamais le droit
de l'avoir, hein? Coudon!
Ça prend-tu un à jackstrap
pour conduire un char astheure?)
D'ailleurs, Yvon Deschamps,
il nous a éduqués par le rire.
D'abord et avant tout.
- Écoutez btststststststststs.
Il y en a des grosses,
il y en a des plates,
il y en a des fermes,
il y en a des slaques,
les fesses
- Vous chantez 10 chansons
d'Yvon Deschamps, dont
"Les fesses".
Vous êtes pas chanteuse.
- Eh
- Alors, comment vous y prenez
pour faire tout ça?
- Bien, c'est une bonne question
parce que, t'sais, souvent les
gens vont dire : "Bien,
Guylaine, elle est pas une
chanteuse, elle a chanté..."
J'ai chanté dans "Belles-
Soeurs", bon, des affaires
comme ça. "Mais c'est pas
une chanteuse." Mais à l'âge
où je suis rendue, c'est plus ça
qui est important. Vraiment pas.
Si j'avais fait
ce spectacle-là à 35 ans...
Je l'aurais pas fait,
premièrement. J'aurais dit :
Bien non, je suis pas une
chanteuse, je suis pas capable
de faire ça, je performera
bien. Rendue où je suis dans
ma vie, la performance n'a plus
l'importance qu'elle avait.
C'est-à-dire que c'est...
Je reviens à
disais, c'est le partage.
Moi, je suis pas une chanteuse,
j'en serai jamais une.
Mais j'ai envie d'interpréter
ces chansons-là et de les
u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'u'elles sont
belles et qu'elles me touchent
infiniment. Bon. C'est sûr que
tu veux les chanter du mieux que
tu peux. Mais Yvon Deschamps é r
remplacer Caruso, admettons, là,
t'sais, dans sa vie. Alors...
Et on s'en foutait complètement.
- Oui, oui.
- Bien, c'est son coeur
qu'il nous livre.
- Ah!
C'était carrément ça.
- C'est son coeur. Alors, moi,
c'est mon coeur que je veux
livrer aussi. Et les chansons
sont si belles, sont si
- Guylaine Tremblay,
merci beaucoup!
- Merci beaucoup!
♪ J'sais pas comment ♪
♪ J'sais pas pourquoi ♪
♪ Faut toujou
que je me retrouve là ♪
♪ À vous racont